hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm not
as cool as ryan right no but she's
salamander Sally and we're gonna check
out the official international trailer
they don't have a domestic one yet for
the big game can't wait to review this
Oh big game I got some big game oh
that's right I'd only use it on one
person then good for you Samuel Jackson
it's probably gonna yell let's do this
Takumi's against our it's a stay on the
very belong to all male in our master
bean commit circuits show Sophie
Meeta
thirty-six minutes ago we got a key back
to signal from Air Force One you think
this is the most serious terrorist
action since my resident of the United
States after hunting never got any
bigger
that guy is in the way
yes
well okay then when the trailer first
started out I thought it was a foreign
film yeah me too I was very confused but
I like that speech they're giving the
whole time of the boy going into the
wilderness and coming out of maan that
speech was pretty much similar to what
my parents were cited when I was born
yeah I grew up like Mowgli that was my
lifestyle I mean the movie looks
interesting for the most part it looks
kind of silly and cheesy but I guess for
a plot any movie that involves the the
President of the United States that is
an action movie it is always really
silly yeah I was thinking an Air Force
One White House down Olympus was falling
like all those [ __ ] films now that we
have a black president they make sure to
cast black guys now to be the president
good for them good for them I am
supportive of this supportive of this
well the fit that woman did it I don't
know I wasn't sure what this trailer was
trying to convince I didn't either it
was all over the place I'm like where
should I feel like Oh should I go to
watch this movie to see their
relationship or for action or for this
weird plot yeah like because they have
like this coming-of-age story with his
kid and then they have this story of the
President and then it's like an action
movie then they're trying to be like
really emotionally heartfelt yeah what
is this film exactly really hard to do
yeah I don't know if this must be a
b-movie but it definitely has a b-movie
Viola that yeah I'm so curious because
I'm still not sure what exactly I'll be
honest I'm not that intrigued yeah I
mean there are several people who said I
should check this trailer out but maybe
we should just like wait for another
trailer we should wait for the domestic
one yeah okay so when it starts off with
the president they're like evacuating it
now explain why a terrorist attack or
something but I thought that would make
sense first a little boy had something
to do with it and so that's why I was
really confused when they like
because I thought you like was chosen to
do something horrible I would say I'm
surprised I got Samuel Jackson but then
Samuel Jackson kind of does anything now
he does a lot of straight-to-dvd movies
and a lot of huge [ __ ] movies at the
same time this might be another case
where the trailer just wasn't done well
maybe just cut together in a weird way I
think it was just a little odd I
couldn't follow what they were trying to
be good at I think at one point in the
trailer the guy wielding a gun through
the helicopter is Kelsey Grammer from
Frasier I mean I think it might be him I
mean he was in the Expendables 3 so
maybe he's trying to be an action hero
now but I saw one of the people
protecting the president was a actor Ray
Stevenson who was always playing bad
guys so something tells me he's a
traitor it's probably one of those
things were the head of the president's
security is really the whole time
there's so much action towards the end
of this trailer and in the president's
light you protected me yeah I'm thinking
like with all the rockets and [ __ ]
flying and all the assault rifles is
this little boy the one who's like
protecting the president the whole time
I mean if the if the movie pulls that
off well I like watching a little kid
kick ass I mean the kick ass of Chloe
Moretz was awesome so yeah and I'm also
wondering what kind of action they're
going for like is it realistic style or
incredibly over-the-top boom it looks it
looks over-the-top but it looks
unintentionally over-the-top like it
doesn't seem it seems like they still
thought the audience would buy this I
don't know it's probably just the
trailer anyway guys thanks for telling
me that trailer is out I will probably
wait til it's on Netflix if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
reel rejects you can check out the
Salamanders Sally channel does a lot of
stuff on there and a lot of skits that
are actually funny that is this sad but
you just think there's sad is your perm
mode
I'm a comedian like get out of here if
you think I'm easy nothing we're gonna
get any shoutouts so say something
interesting and earned yourself a
shout-out at facebook.com slash the real
reject shoutouts are you yawning in the
middle of a video what kind of
professional are you right now I pay you
nothing and this is what you give me
right wait no there's a real business I
don't even know how the raisin thing was
a joke yeah they're white though I
wonder how they got white co2 hidden is
that a seaman reference and you put it
in your mouth that is what she just did